what's up guys it's Greg here I'm
wearing a marble shirt because that
upsets people when it's a DC trailer no
I'm a my shirts are actually all being
clean right now this is the only clean
shirt I have I don't have many shirts
unite the league cyborg
Wow
[Applause]
[Music]
you know despite all the sarcasm and all
the crap I've been given the DCE you I
do have faith in this movie I just want
that to be known I feel like people
think I have no absolute faith in this
film and I really do it I think this
should at least be fun I think it's
going to be really fun
right now cyborg it looks really badass
he's really the wild card right now so
far with the promotion's of Justice
League Cyprus got on the least attention
primarily because no one really knows
who's cyborg is I don't really know
who's cyborg is the most I know about
cyborg is when I played in justice and
he's a really cool character and I know
he likes to say Booya which is what I
say after every time I take a [ __ ] and
I'm sure if and when he does say the
words Booya in the movie everyone's
gonna lose their [ __ ] it was a fan of
him saying Booya and I've heard some
people complain about cyborg just being
all CGI I mean you really can't it's
gonna be very hard at all practical I'm
not gonna give the movie crap at all for
making cyborgs primarily CGI and as a
guy who's a fan of the Marvel movies
there's Marvel characters who are there
primarily just CGI the Hulk CGI so as a
guy who really loves the Marvel films
and if people are going to call me a
Marvel fan boy for like not like in the
DC EU films I'm here to say I'm okay
with cyborg being CGI cuz I can see how
it's close to impossible to really do
all of a cyborgs not CGI but so far he's
been getting the least attention and
trailers and marketing it's cool that he
has one of the few sneak peek promos of
the unites the league really hoping he
gets a chance to stand out I'm hoping
that people really like this character
you know he's like the underdog for me
because now many people know who he is I
would honestly love it if when this
movie is all said and done
people are like cyborg was my favorite
character actually he was the coolest
one he was most relatable any time we
see cyborg it's really just the designs
of the guy and he you know he does like
a couple of cool things here or there
the only complaint I could really give
about the marketing with them showing
cyborg is that he kind of has the same
facial expression for anything he's
doing in any of the images we get of him
I like to see a little bit more of him I
like to be more excited for him and I
want more people to feel excited for him
as well come on he's the only black guy
in the Justice League we need to be
excited for him
all right well you can subscribe to the
real rejects follow me on Instagram and
Twitter and by the way I know the
official trailers coming out on Saturday
I have an event to go to on Saturday so
if it drops before like 3:50 p.m. before
I have to head out over an hour away
from where I live I can definitely have
it up on Saturday but if it doesn't drop
by then you might have to wait till
Sunday for all you guys who are gonna be
look where's your [ __ ] Justice League
reaction that's why it's gonna be
delayed let's hope it drops early